are there other projects that pop to
mind from the space exploration
initiative or maybe stuff from the book
the that you can mention something super
cool i mean everything we've been
talking about is cool but just something
that pops to mind again yeah um so we
talked about life in space and you might
need more arms than legs uh one of the
projects by valentina sumini was a
air-powered robotics tail
so it's a soft robotics tail that
essentially has a little camera on the
back end of it can do computer vision
and knows where to grapple so it's
behind you it grapples onto something
and holds you in space and then you can
actually free up both of your hands to
work so we're already starting to think
about the design of bionic humans or
prosthetics or things that would make
you kind of like a cyborg to augment
your capabilities when you're in a space
environment would you control something
like that so it's kind of like a
i mean you can't call it a leg
but whatever it's a traditional
appendage appendage so how would you
what are ideas for controlling something
like that yeah so right now it's super
yes there you go that's cool right now
it's super manual um
it's uh basically just like a kind of a
set pattern of inflating as we're
testing it but in the future if we had a
neural link i mean this is something
that you could imagine directly
controlling just thinking thoughts and
controlling it that's a ways away yeah
so we talked about on the biology side
astrobiology there's probably
agriculture stuff
is there other things that kind of feed
the ecosystem of out in space for
survival or or the robotics
architectures the self-assembly stuff so
kind of combining something we were
talking about uh you can form these
relationships with objects and
anthropomorphize yes one of the things
that we're thinking about for
agriculture created by
manway and somu so two students at mit
was this little it looks like a planet
uh but it's inspired by i think a
mandala or nepalese spinning wheel and
you plant plants on the inside and the
astronaut has to spin it every day to
help the plants survive so it's a way to
give the astronauts something to care
about something that they are
responsible for keeping alive and can
really
invest themselves in and it's not
necessary right we have other ways to
grow in orbit
hydroponics liquid medium trying to keep
the liquid around the plant roots is
hard because there's no gravity to pull
it down in a particular direction but
what i loved about this project was they
said
sure we have ways that the plants could
grow on their own but the astronauts
might want to care for it in the same
way that we have little plants that come
to be important to us little plant
friends yeah so there's agrifuge that's
an early model of this spinning manually
spinning plant habitat
you